hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
hey okay it's Tara Eric Erickson - Tara
we're gonna do a try not to laugh
challenge this video is titled if you
don't laugh you are a stone-faced god
I'm a stone face God asked if I know any
stand-up comedians like Tara they don't
laugh at anyone else's jokes because
they think oh you gotta analyze every
fricking joke that comes out of
someone's noggin actually laugh at open
mics okay thank you give pity labs no
it's real it's you job all right so
here's the deal Tara what's the deal you
cannot laugh do I get paid if I don't
laugh no no no no I only pay the male
guests that come on this channel like
Mark Wahlberg that's how I like to
operate that's me just knocking over
everything I it would have been cooler
if it actually sure they're not you
didn't just come from an improv class
time to go
[Music]
we'll get in the buckle it'll burn where
are you man they won't be able to sit
down because of the burning get that but
Oh dad you're drooling a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
apparently kid see good
okay I was gonna be terrible no most of
these videos kids hurting themselves oh
wow
start again
[Music]
good so what is wrong with that cat it's
funny kids bet whoa oh my god no that's
child abuse of these videos are kids
getting hurt
[Music]
oh no definitely not
oh no oh my god in 48 year men from
Somalia
[Music]
my name's Scott Bradford 1920 like the
center of the onion I know how to die
soon
[Music]
[Music]
nothing finer than the urging gear
[Music]
what's happening at the dog yeah
I thought they were making dog noises
the humans that was weird
[Music]
okay what kind of genius loses a billion
dollars this guy he's your type he is
just everything that's happening is just
like get over here at a park
[Music]
my forged a my fragment my bargains am i
pregnant
Wow 980 right my pregnant or am i okay
could I be regulate how do I know if I'm
friend Dan can I be pregnant
can I get like on tape right now what
happened when you get will my get to
brag man what is the best time to sex -
anyone know how many know what women has
starch masks on her body does that mean
I still get wax can I use the old grits
before find out I am pregnant last five
weeks so can I start sex dangerous brand
six will it hurt baby top on his head me
and my boyfriend are time to get
pregnant rule 38 + two weeks right
Gannon I think I'm 40
sorry guys camera cut Susan were present
where we were
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one guy do all this I guess we learned
today that we are not stone-faced gods
Tara you broke early did the dog runs
right in a chair and his recovery time
is literally 0.5 seconds he's like I'm
Cole the mark of a true comedian is one
who does not laugh at others jokes or
anything funny in a video running into a
chair so boom shocka don't got me there
most of this was like kids getting hurt
almost dying a couple of them just laid
there like I was like are you okay one
dad threw like this giant block of ice
at again crying like Europe come on I
mean I feel like stuff a random children
all the time yeah but but it's like it's
like coke cans it's like a full cocaine
at the head and like my cat and it's not
being recorded
totally nobody's there recording and
it's noting see no one can see it
don't tell anyone I threw this cat at
you I get it and then it's easy you just
you throw the cat the kids like whoa
he's gonna throw a cat stay out of his
way it's the easiest way to cover up
anything is by threatening the children
have a good threatener you think you're
good
how do you how do you threaten to show
me a threatened face you hey kid that's
it tell anyone I put a bullet in your
mother's head that's the where I ha ha I
don't believe you
no that's how I do it really yeah I'd be
like because my actual voice ain't scary
I can get scary you guys just were they
were scared just then meet me doing my
thing well you're naturally scary yeah
but like I can get scary anyone born
from 1965 is pretty scary totally I mean
it's completely freaking terrifying that
wasn't that was just intense Amy hammer
throw a cat out cha like where are we
it's not scary you were born nobody was
scared though I mean fine from what I
was born that's my era I'm totally here
you don't get it if I say it in that
voice I'll be like come on guys I was
just joking with the kid why would I do
that voice if I was being serious but
the kid registers our vocabulary so he
is scared but my cover up is the voice I
did he's flipping it he's doing a floor
oh yeah no you got a cover you got
copper tracks saying all right I just I
don't think anybody's ever scared hey
how you doing I'm gonna uh I'll shoot
you in the head you don't give me your
money huh if I had an actual good on me
which I usually do when I'm talking to
the kids yeah that's useful what what is
it a Glock no good old m16 I care here
you just come out with it yeah I just
carried in my back pocket and then they
immediately leave so really you've made
up yeah story cuz you don't have to kid
me I'm spraying okay right like spraying
paint the town red say yeah I say stuff
like that this has become really fun
alright kids well you can subscribe to
the real rejects and you can find me too
on the youtubes I just looking at my
knight in Terra Eric's Tareq Singh go
join the idiot
me Thank you very you did well kid and
yeah Tara left before I did meaning
she's not that funny I felt him inside
he was building up dude help me inside
why was she inside of me
nobody knows cuz normally its flipped
that's what he said she said I've never
been in OK in anyone listen I'll close
out on some New Jersey